you
ingrates
you whiny entitled brats yeah yeah i'm
talking about you
you're complaining because what because
everything is way more expensive now
than it used to be
and
and what because the economy is
sputtering
and the government isn't letting you run
your business or do your job or even
travel if you don't comply with a bunch
of extremely burdensome and expensive
regulations
without even acknowledging the great
successes
of this administration without even
admitting that gas has dropped
10 cents per gallon this month
here it is buster can't deny that so
stop complaining
and get used to the new normal i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from aaron levitt
who says the dude beating everyone on
the women's swim team reminds me of the
seinfeld episode where cramer joins a
kid's karate class and when questioned
by jerry about it claimed that it was
fair because they're all at the same
skill level kramer of course won every
fight in the class and thought he was
awesome that is an apt
uh analogy you're right i think that's
very similar the only difference being
seinfeld
was a sitcom
and the dude on the pens swim team
is ostensibly living in reality
but our reality has become like an
episode of seinfeld or always sunny or
something perhaps even more absurd it
just it gets you a little tense
sometimes and when you're when you're
feeling a little tense especially at the
office you gotta check out x chair i've
gotta give you a massage
that's right you lucky duck but i'm not
gonna be doing it with my hands i don't
wanna get me tooed i don't want anyone
to file an hr complaint against me okay
but i am gonna i'm gonna help you get a
massage at the office with
x chair x chair is
incredible i love it it is by far the
coolest piece of furniture in the entire
daily wire studios it's just tremendous
it is this ergonomically designed chair
it's
i don't listen i don't know anything
about science but it's super duper
sciency and it just puts you in this
great kind of posture it can warm you up
it can cool you down it can massage you
all at the office it's incredible and
right now x chairs christmas present to
you is that you can save 100
off of your x-chair
you can do that by going to
xchairknowles.com is xchairnulls.com the
letter x
chair
knowles
kowles.com ex chair has a 30-day
guarantee of complete comfort and you
can finance your purchase for as little
as 30 per month go to externals.com and
save that's exchairknowles.com
right now gas is down 10 cents per
gallon we've been told that
the inflation rate is hitting record
highs and we've been told for instance
that the consumer price inflation rate
in the united states is 6.8 according to
the bureau of labor statistics that's a
very high number and that should
should really concern everybody because
your wealth is just disappearing before
your very eyes and you are losing
purchasing power
but i am here to tell you the situation
is actually much much much worse than
that even that 6.8 percent number even
there's another number about wholesale
price increases that's closer to 10
but even those numbers do not come
anywhere near representing the scope of
the problem
so this is the the largest
year-over-year increase
in consumer prices since uh june of 1982
since the early
early days of the reagan administration
this is the sixth straight month in
which inflation remained above five
percent
but it's much higher if you talk about
fruits and vegetables then the prices
have gone up four percent year over year
that's pretty high i was talking to sean
spicer yesterday and he was complaining
that the price of lemons he loves lemons
for whatever reason he was complaining
that the price of lemons
has gone way up milk 4.6
apparel 5 food 6.1 percent electricity
6.5 jewelry
6.7 okay so now we're at that right
around that number where the consumer
price inflation is 6.8
what about domestic services
home care or maybe cleaning maybe those
sorts of things 10.2
new cars
11.1 percent
furniture and bedding you need some new
sheets for your bed 11.8 percent now
we're just getting into food like meat
and chicken and fish
is up
13.1 percent year-over-year hotels gonna
be traveling this christmas i was just
traveling i just stayed at a hotel it
was much more expensive than usual
25.5
used cars so not new new cars already up
very high used cars up
31.4 percent and then you get to gas
gas is up
58.1 percent
year over year that's pretty high
now the gas fell in the last month 10
does that or 10 10 cents rather not 10
10 cents does that make up for the 58.1
percent increase year over year i don't
think so
even the numbers we're getting out of
the establishment media in the corporate
press are hiding the real costs of
inflation so whose fault is it whose
fault is it well if you ask the white
house you ask jen saki she says it is
everyone else's fault
it is not the white house's fault it's
not the biden policies
you want someone to blame blame the
cattle ranchers
the president thinks the way people
across the country american families
digest inflation is by price increases
and if you look at industry to industry
it's a little different so for example
the president the secretary of
agriculture have both spoken to what
we've seen as the greed of meat
conglomerates that is an area where
people go to the grocery store and
they're trying to buy a pound of meat
two pounds of meat 10 pounds of meat
it is the prices are higher that is in
his view
and the view of our secretary of
agriculture because of you could call it
corporate greed short you could call it
jacking up prices
during a pandemic uh there are other
areas where we've seen increases uh
because of supply chain issues and we're
seeing those increases around the world
as it relates to gas prices uh oil
supply and things along those lines so i
would say there's some areas where we
have seen uh corporations uh benefit
profit from the pandemic uh and uh and
certainly the president would agree with
that component it's corporate greed the
meat industry so meat's only up what
13.1 percent so can you imagine the the
hotel greed the used car greed the gas
greed
it's their f stop being so greedy guys
when when the the ranchers and the meat
industry
are raising their prices
but because their costs are increasing
and so they've they've gotta they can't
be just losing money right they've got
to keep making a profit to stay afloat
that's very greedy
when the biden administration hikes your
taxes
during a pandemic during a lockdown
during tough times that's not greedy
biden right now is trying to hike your
taxes
a lot
that's not greedy that's that's actually
that's just you paying your fair share
that's actually compassionate of joe
biden but when the meat industry raises
prices because their costs are going up
that's
extremely greedy when joe biden
shuts down oil pipelines and raises the
price of gas
to pay for his
ridiculous
and end of the world
climate change agenda that's
compassionate that's one that's not
greedy
when he charges you a bunch when he
takes your money to pay for his
delusions that's not greedy when he
takes your money to pay off teacher
unions that vote for him when he takes
your money to put out little goodies in
the hands of
his political donors and his political
supporters that's not greedy
but when some rancher
in the middle of america raises prices
because he asked because his costs are
right that it's always someone else's
fault right it's always somebody
else's fault what happened
to shutting down the virus do you
remember i'm sure joe biden does not
since he doesn't remember what he had
for breakfast do you remember that
during
the 2020 campaign
joe biden debating donald trump
trump was nailing biden as a lot of
republicans were saying you're going to
shut down the country we're the we're
the side of don't shut down the country
you biden or the side of shutting down
the country and biden said i'm not going
to shut down the country i'm going to
shut down the virus
what i would say is i'm going to shut
down the virus not the country it's his
ineptitude that caused that caused the
country to have to shut down in large
part why businesses have gone under why
schools are closed why so many people
have lost their living and why they're
concerned those other concerns are real
that's why he should have been instead
of in a sand trap in his golf course he
should have been negotiating with nancy
pelosi and the rest of the democrats and
republicans about what to do about the
acts they were passing for billions of
dollars to make sure people had the
capacity so biden's obviously a little
confused about many things including his
history here because at the beginning of
the covid nonsense it was trump and the
republicans who wanted to shut down the
border not the virtual border with china
wanted to shut down travel with china
and it was joe biden who called that
hysterical xenophobia and wanted to keep
the borders open and still has the
borders open
on our southern border
it was donald trump who wanted to shut
that down it was donald trump who wanted
to keep the country open
after the two weeks to slow the spread
and it was biden and all of the
democrats who wanted to keep the country
shut down and dr fauci
and and the public health bureaucrats
they wanted to keep the whole country
shut down and now and so joe biden in
2020 was trying to weasel out of it he
said i don't want to shut the country
down even though that's what i've been
advocating since the beginning i just
want to shut down the virus well
all of that to say the cdc director
rachelle wolinski has just gone on
television to tell you that as we head
into year two
we're not shutting the virus down
shouldn't the messaging be though
rochelle's we sit here there because
we're going into year two people think
we're waiting for you to sound the trump
and say it's all clear we're not really
going to get an all clear are we we just
have to face the fact that we're going
to have to live with this true i think
that that's probably too true but what i
would say is we have a lot of control
and power to do that as we come together
as we get vaccinated as we do those
prevention things that work to protect
one another and ourselves and our family
we can bring down the amount of disease
in this country and get much faster to
that place
yeah that's that's probably true we're
just gonna have to live with the virus
we're never ever ever going to shut it
down and i have to correct the lady who
asked the question of rachelle wolenski
she said as we head into year two and
that seems like such a long time right
it was supposed to be two weeks to slow
the spread how are we heading into year
two we're not
we're not heading into year two
we're heading into year three
can you believe that we're heading into
year three
it's already been almost two years
it started in
early 2020 they said two weeks to slow
the spread that took all of 2020
and then it took all of 2021 and now
they're telling us it's going to keep
going on
and on and on and it's everybody else's
fault
it's trump's fault for whatever reason
it's your fault for not wearing the mask
it's your fault for not getting the
vaccine it's your fault for not getting
the 15th booster it's your fault
for
wanting your political rights back and
oh the vaccines and the masks and the
lockdowns that doesn't prevent you from
going into years and years and years
more of this well
i don't know blame the meat industry you
know it's enough to keep you up at night
but when you want to sleep very well at
night i would strongly recommend you
check out helix i have to invite you
into my bed
i do i do not it wouldn't literally be
my bed
my wife would not like that maybe she
would like it frankly i don't know you
know she'd be able to go to her own bed
she'd probably have a nice time we would
both have to have helix beds in that
case because helix is phenomenal and i
what i'm saying is i want you to have
your own helix because you shouldn't be
sleeping in a bed that's for somebody
else okay you should be sleeping in a
bed that is just for you helix has a
quiz it takes two minutes to complete it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else
even if it's me
head on over to helix right now you're
getting the mattress that is the perfect
fit for the way you sleep whether you
sleep maybe you sleep a little bit hot
maybe you like a firmer mattress they
will just tailor it perfectly to your
preferences they've got a 10-year
warranty you can try it out for 100
nights for free they'll even pick it up
if you don't love it but you are going
to love it so head on over right now to
helixsleep.com canada view les take
their two minute sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life they're offering up to 200 bucks
off all mattresses and two free pillows
for our listeners helix sleep.com
knowles up to 200 off and two free
pillows
so the cdc director goes out and says no
you're not going back to normal
stop complaining the white house comes
on and says yeah your prices are going
up but hey stop complaining if you want
to complain to somebody go complain to
the ranchers in montana or something
don't don't bug me about it and now joe
biden has lost it he's lost his temper
he he just he wants you to take the 17th
booster shot or whatever number we're on
now he just
why won't you take oh cause you want
your freedom
you want well joe biden says if you want
your freedom if you want your regular
way of life that just means you're not a
patriot and you got to get over yourself
everybody talks about freedom and not to
have a to have a shot or have a test
well guess what and so how about
patriotism how about making sure that
you're vaccinated so you do not spread
the disease to anybody else what about
that
what's the big deal
what's the big deal be a patriot
says the guy whose party hates america
i'm not being hyperbolic here they hate
america they protest the american flag
they disrespect the symbol of america
they constantly talk about how america
is an evil rotten country the worst
country in the history of the world
irredeemably corrupted because of the
original sin of slavery and it's racist
and bigoted and terrible and xenophobia
and that's it's the worst country ever
so be a patriot why should i be a
patriot you're telling me this country's
terrible
so i guess i shouldn't be a patriot
now of course
biden is not applying particularly
rigorous logic these days but the left
broadly isn't either
you remember andrew cuomo back when
everyone everyone on the left was in
love with cuomo and they gave him that
big multi-million dollar book deal and
people were calling themselves
homosexuals and he was being heralded as
the greatest governor ever and he was
speaking at the democrat national
convention in 2020
cuomo
said we're america tough we're america
tough and we're going to get together
because we're great americans but just a
few months earlier he said that america
was never that great a few years earlier
i should be fair he was talking about
about donald trump
trump said make america great again what
did andrew cuomo say on camera he said
america was never that great
but then he totally switches and he says
we're america tough well which is it do
you love your country do you not love
your country
for the left it's just whatever is
convenient and then biden says what's
the big deal about getting vaccinated
okay good i'm glad that that's your
argument let's hold you to that argument
that it's not a big deal
so if it's not a big deal to get
vaccinated then it's not a big deal to
not get vaccinated right what's the big
deal the libs do this all the time with
the gender pronouns
they'll say michael come on what's the
big deal about calling a guy who
pretends to be a woman she what's the
big deal oh good i'm glad i'm glad we
agree
that it's not it's not a big deal okay
good then it's not a big deal for me to
call him a he
well no it actually it is it's a really
big deal if you call him a he
oh okay so why is it a big deal it's a
big deal in the case of the pronouns
it's a big deal because the pronouns
carry with it whole premises if i call a
man who's pretending to be a woman if i
call that hulking dude from the pens
women's swim team if i call him she
i'm accepting the insane and politically
very potent left-wing premise that men
can become women and that sex is not
real and that human nature is completely
changeable
and so i'm not going to do that because
i think that's a big deal and it's the
same thing with the vaccine
if you're telling me
that
some egghead bureaucrat
who has
been around and in power for seven u.s
presidents he's the highest-paid
employee of the federal government if
you're telling me that this guy
can force 330 million people to take an
experimental drug to maybe
possibly protect against a virus that
does not pose a particularly grave risk
to the vast majority of people and he
can just do that
based on his own whims and his caprices
that would seem to be a fundamental
restructuring of of the constitutional
order and so i think
that's a pretty big deal
that's the big if you're telling me that
the federal government can force you
to inject yourself with morally
compromised vaccines
that maybe it is permissible to take the
vaccines but it is still
a remote cooperation with evil because
all of the vaccines were at least
developed if not also produced using the
stem cells of aborted babies if you're
telling me the government can just force
you to do that
to to possibly protect against a virus
that does not pose a great threat to the
vast majority of people that seems like
a big deal to me
but of course they think it is a big
deal that's why they're putting all
their political capital behind it just
like they think the the pronouns are a
big deal too and they're gaslighting you
even though gas is extremely expensive
now thanks in no small part to joe biden
they're gaslighting you
into believing it's not a big deal but
of course it is speaking of patriotism
governor ron desantis once again doing
the right thing ron desantis sent out a
press release yesterday saying that
florida quote stands ready to aid the
response efforts
from all impacted states after those
terrible deadly tornadoes that ripped
through a little bit ripped through
nashville but really hit mostly in
kentucky
the florida division of emergency
management
is coordinating right now with the
offices of quote the nine affected
states to identify resource gaps and
offer support as needed including urban
search and rescue teams ambulance strike
teams and recovery disaster specialists
there are so many aspects to this story
and they're all brilliant
okay on just on the political and the
electoral politics level ron desantis
yet again is figuring a way to put
himself
right at the heart of a national news
story why is a kentucky
tornado
putting ron desantis in the national
media spotlight well because he's
offering to help them and then other
governors are not doing that in a very
public way and so that's putting him
there so if the guy wants to run for
president he's positioning himself very
well to do so
but beyond just the electoral politics
stuff it's the right thing to do and
this is going to
irritate a certain breed of libertarian
there's a certain breed of libertarian
who's going to say this is just
desantis
illegitimately using his state resources
and his constituents resources to put
himself in the national spotlight it's a
dereliction of duty for he should just
be focused on the people of florida what
has florida to do with kentucky
what have you to do with me this is no
as is a bad use of resources and
no you know do you know what florida has
to do with kentucky
they're part of the same country that's
what and actually actually it's a good
thing when states help out other states
and not only is that not some
irresponsible left-wing big government
dereliction of duty that's the right
thing to do because we're countrymen
that's what you want you want a nation
to have some cohesion
the founding fathers thought the nation
needed cohesion
we did have national cohesion
until very recently now we have
basically nothing holding us together
america
does not have
a
particular race
there used to be
a little bit more racial cohesion but
you know it was always kind of
complicated because there were multiple
races here
we no longer really have religious
cohesion at all
we don't religion is plummeting in
america and there's a lot of religious
diversity
we no longer have linguistic cohesion
even we don't even speak the same
language anymore
both because of the growth of spanish as
an american language and because the
libs just keep changing the meanings of
all the words we don't so we don't have
a lot holding us together we don't even
have a love of the same ideals or the
same symbols or the same founding
fathers or anything half the country's
tearing down the statues half the
country is spitting on the american flag
and the other half
is saluting the flag
half the country
i suspect
identifies much more with the rainbow
flag than they do with the stars and
stripes
and so what desantis is doing here is
he's saying you know we are part of one
country we're gonna go
we're going to go help out kentucky i
love it i think it's great stuff it's
really smart it's not only good politics
but it's right and it gets to a much
deeper kind of conservatism than the
frivolous you know just cut my taxes and
leave me alone stuff that we've heard
for the past 20 years speaking of a more
robust conservatism you're not only
seeing it from the conservative
republican governor of florida
you're seeing a strange
leaning into a kind of conservatism
coming from
pop music
you're seeing it come from
someone named billy eilish
now i'm no expert on billy eilish okay
i've never listened to a billy eilish
tune i wouldn't really be able to pick
her out of a lineup
but billy eilish
has just come out
and uh and made a very conservative
point she
she's come out against porn as a woman i
think porn is a disgrace and i
used to
watch a lot of porn to be honest i
started watching porn when i was like
11.
and
um
you know it's
i i didn't understand why it was a a bad
thing i thought i thought that's how you
learned how to have sex and i used to be
like the person that would like talk
about porn all the time i'd be like oh
so stupid that anybody would think that
porn is bad or [ __ ] up or you know i
think it's so cool and it's great and
it's and it's what kind of porn were you
watching i was an advocate and i
you know thought i was one of the guys
and would talk about it and think it was
really cool for for for not having a
problem with it and not seeing why it
was
bad and you know i uh
i think it really destroyed my brain and
um i feel
incredibly
devastated that i
was exposed to so much porn
am i listening to the howard stern show
or the mailbag
on this show where a lot of young people
mostly men but occasionally sometimes
women write in and make the same exact
point that billy eilish is making
it's really some people recognize that
we're living in a strange time and and
they're
they're changing their views because of
that like for instance your view on your
mortgage rate which is why you got to
check out american financing mortgage
rates remain incredibly low but that
might not be the case forever are they
going to stay at that level in the new
year we can't be sure which is why you
need to call american financing lock
into a low rate now and potentially save
yourself up to a thousand dollars a
month that's right per
month you can even skip your january
mortgage payment and possibly february
creating greater savings as we begin a
new year think of how much that can help
and then give american financing a call
there's no pressure
no obligation no upfront or hidden fees
just a simple conversation about ways
that you can save without restarting
your loan
that's right you can choose any term 10
years and over so you're not wasting
money on years that you don't need get a
free mortgage review today when you call
800-685-5696 that is
800-685-5696 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls
182-334-nmls consumeraccess.org
you know not only was the daily wire the
first company in the nation to sue the
biden administration for their
unconstitutional mandate but we are
getting closer closer and closer to our
goal of one million signatures on our do
not comply petition every single day
people are realizing that if we do not
actively fight for our freedom and our
way of life and our rights and the
america that we all know and love
radicals are going to take it from us
new york city
new york city is expanding the vaccine
mandate to kids ages 5 through 11.
they're forcing a bunch of kids who
statistically have an infinitesimally
small chance of serious complications of
covid they're forcing them to take this
experimental drug we right now have over
878 000 signatures
we need your help to cross that finish
line so please sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply then share
the petition with all of your friends
and family send a message to biden and
fauci and all the rest of those jerks
who are trying to take away our way of
life we'll be right back with a lot more
right wing retrograde
activist um
billy eilish is coming out against porn
is she no she's not she's not
a bible thumper
or a
reactionary or retrograde or any of
these things she's
about as pop mainstream
lib as it gets and she's saying that she
feels that that porn destroyed her brain
because she
like so many people who are in gen z and
millennials to a lesser degree
millennials were exposed to porn at a
pretty early age too but
uh less so than than gen z where
basically they're just saturated in it
from the moment they're born
she she says that being exposed to this
at a young age and getting addicted to
it is destroying her brain people right
into my mailbag all the time
as you have heard on this topic
and they say i know that i'm supposed to
be cool and hip and we're all supposed
to be fine with porn and actually pro
porn but i think it's bad and maybe
we've got to do something about this
problem they're recognizing this because
it is true
and
they're recognizing that while the way
that
the porn industry and the sexual
revolutionaries sold porn is that it's a
way to increase your freedom don't let
the those old constraints and those old
nasty preacher men tell you what to do
man you know just just enjoy your
freedom to watch women be degraded
that's how it was sold and virtually
everybody in the culture
at some point has given into this
temptation or even believed that lie
outright
but it turns out it's not true it
doesn't make you free it actually
enslaves you it gets you addicted to
things and it warps your brain and billy
eilish was talking about how she got
really addicted to this particularly
violent kind of porn and it messed up
her relationships and it actually does
change your brain chemistry so there are
actually physical effects of this as
well and obviously extremely corrosive
psychological and spiritual effects
and it seems to me the only people who
don't get it
are the squishy right wingers the
hard left understands what this stuff
does porn and drugs and this culture of
licentiousness they know what it does
and they are wielding it actively
wielding it to compromise your freedom
and change the culture they write about
this i actually write about them writing
about this in my book speechless which
makes a great christmas present by the
way number one national bestseller great
gift to give to your friends or family
so the hard left notes about this the
conservatives the actual conservatives
know that
but it's just the sometimes they're
called the libertarians you know the
very unserious squishy just you do you
types who who kind of fall on the right
they seem to be the only ones who don't
get it
that this is a really powerful thing
and when you legalize all porn just like
if you legalize all drugs just if you
legalize all manner of licentiousness
advice that's not going to free you it's
going to enslave you and it's going to
enslave you to bad dudes on the left
billy eilish gets it you should too
speaking of licentiousness and creepy
sex stuff
abby shapiro just got in trouble abby
shapiro was not doing anything creepy or
not abby shapiro got in trouble for a
tweet
in which she called out this kind of
thing so abby for those of you who don't
know abby is ben's sister
obviously a friend of ours for many many
years and abby has her own channel
called classically abby where she
advocates for a more traditional normal
kind of lifestyle so she sent out this
tweet
two pictures side by side
one is nancy reagan with her family i
guess at the reagan ran looks like it's
at the reagan ranch and one is of
madonna who is now in her 60s
dressed up like she's
a much younger woman doing much
nastier things than 60 year old women
should be doing
abby writes from the classically abbey
account this is madonna at 63 this is
nancy reagan at 64. trashy living versus
classy living which version of yourself
do you want to be
and she was pilloried for this the tweet
went viral
molly jong fast who is a left-wing
writer writing in the daily beast said
that abby classically abby and her
brother ben they're just boomers they're
like millennial boomers
if you criticize
madonna a boomer for her boomer
lifestyle you're apparently a boomer and
if you criticize libs for indulging it
you're apparently
a boomer of course the opposite would be
true but but even just on then the left
were attacking nancy reagan they were
pulling up some tabloid bs biography and
saying that nancy reagan was actually
herself promiscuous back in hollywood
which is which is not true there's no
evidence of it there were two actresses
by the same name nancy reagan's maiden
name is nancy davis there's another
actress named nancy davis there's no
evidence that nancy reagan the lady who
became nancy reagan was ever promiscuous
there is
a fair bit of evidence that the other
nancy davis was perhaps and so anyway
they're just getting that wrong and then
the left is they're making all these
sorts of ugly claims about nancy reagan
but furthermore furthermore
anyone who is claiming that they would
rather be like madonna alone on a bed
dressed up like a hooker intentionally
dressed she's dressed up like a hooker
to be sexually provocative in her 60s
that that's what you want to be rather
than having your family around you
dressed up like a normal respectable
person on your nice ranch they're lying
to you that's obviously
a lie
if you if you really think you'd rather
be dressed up like a hooker on a bed
alone at age 63 rather than standing
around your nice family with you know
everyone who loves you and you know
dressed normally
then
either that that is evidence of a
disordered will your will has been so
corrupted maybe by porn or maybe just by
a lot of bad ideas and a lot of bad
behaviors in your life or
it's just a fatal dose of copium you are
lying to yourself and trying to cope
with your own
bad views and decisions and and uh
and way that you have lived your life
but
nobody i don't think anybody who is in
their right mind could look at those two
pictures and actually say no i really no
i really do want to be like madonna no
you don't she looks miserable okay and
nancy reagan looks happy
relatively this is a tough world there's
always problems everybody's got problems
but
everyone wants to end up like the
picture on the right not like the
picture
on the left
speaking of the sexual revolution
just uh yesterday the the era state of
arizona requested that the united states
supreme court
weigh in on a new pro-life law so there
are these pro-life laws cropping up all
over the country and there are different
pro-life laws the pro-life law in texas
for instance is a law that allows people
ordinary citizens of texas to sue
abortionists
and in this way effectively prohibit
abortion the pro-life law in mississippi
bans abortions after 15 weeks so before
viability as defined by the supreme
court this law in arizona bans abortion
that is done because of genetic
abnormalities so right now it's very
common
to when when a woman becomes pregnant
the woman and hopefully her husband go
into the doctor and they're talking
about how excited they are about their
little bundle of joy and you look at a
sonogram and at a certain point the
doctor almost 100 percent of the time
will say okay we're now we're just going
to screen for some genetic issues
and pro-life people tend to respond to
that and say uh why
what do you mean why are you gonna scan
virgin oh well just because then we'll
just decide how to proceed
what do you mean decide how to proceed i
guess that one thing you could do if you
scan for certain issues sometimes you
can do surgery while the baby's in the
womb and so okay that would be one
reason but that's that's not why most
people do it and that's not what most
doctors are thinking of what they are
saying is well you know we're gonna
screen for down syndrome
oh why why do i
what are you not gonna operate on the
kid and cure the down syndrome so why
well because then we'll figure out how
to proceed
and what they mean is
they're going to do a test to figure out
if your kid's [ __ ] and if your kid's
[ __ ] you're going to kill it that's
what they're saying
and i'm using blunt language for a
reason here because we have all these
euphemisms what we're going to screen
for abnormalities and then we'll decide
if you want to use your your choice and
your reproductive health to continue
with the prayer no what you're saying is
you think that we should kill [ __ ]
people is what you're saying and you you
think that it's perfectly normal to do
that and that's what a just and serious
society does but of course it's only a
ghastly and cruel society
that would do that so arizona rightly is
passing a law saying no we shouldn't we
shouldn't kill [ __ ] people or people
who have any other sorts of
difficulties and and it's just wrong to
do that we're not going to do it and of
course the libs are up in arms about it
and that's going to go up to the supreme
court
this is great i'm glad this is going to
the supreme court i'm glad it's going to
the supreme court now while the supreme
court is considering the more important
abortion case dobbs versus jackson
women's health organization
i am for the kitchen sink approach here
the kitchen sink approach meaning i want
there to be seven billion different
pro-life laws on the books all
challenging roe versus wade all
challenging planned parenthood vkc and
maybe they're for different reasons and
maybe they've got different arguments
and justifications and maybe they do
different things
but the ultimate effect is going to be
stop killing babies for whatever reason
because they got down syndrome because
of their sex because the race because of
because the mother just doesn't like
them because the father doesn't like
them because we have this insane cult
whatever the reason
the way that
abortion became codified unjustly into
u.s law was the kitchen sink approach
the libs just kept bringing cases for
different reasons they kept inventing
new rights in the constitution and then
they would invent new rights based on
those rights so you'd have a right to an
abortion found in the the emanations and
the penumbras of certain provi it was
just completely made up
but because they threw the kitchen sink
in
because they just
used everything they had
abortion's been on the books for almost
50 years now
planned parenthood v casey changes this
is the case in 1992 changes the
reasoning
for why we need to have abortion why
there's a fake constitutional right to
abortion from roe versus wade in 1973
and yet it doesn't matter the effect was
the same so i think we should do the
same thing now's the time
maybe the court is going to squish they
usually do
but we've ostensibly got six
conservative judges
roe v wade is probably the single most
egregious decision in the history of the
united states time to
get rid of it
traditional views of human nature
really basic stuff like babies or babies
and boys or not girls
are winning political issues the libs
have convinced us they've convinced not
us but they've convinced a lot of
squishes that if you stand up and say
don't kill babies that's going to be a
big loser when you're running for office
oh you can't you can't go out and say
that you think we shouldn't
kill babies because oh you're going to
lose votes you're not going to get
elected you've got to take the position
that we should be able to kill babies up
until nine months in the womb and then
then that'll be really popular that's
what the people want there's no evidence
of that same thing on this on the sexual
identity stuff
if you dare say that men are not really
women you're going to look like a crazy
retrograde reactionary that's such an
unpopular view don't you don't you deny
that there's such a thing as
transgenderism and that the soul has
nothing to do with the body oh you'll
lose bs that's a winner we just won a
race in virginia over this
transgenderism
is probably the number one reason why
glenn yonkin won his race in virginia
and beat terry mcauliffe because a dude
in a skirt walked into a girl's bathroom
and raped a girl in loudoun county and
then the school covered it up and sent
him to another school and he did
basically the same thing again
and parents were outraged over this and
voters were outraged and they booted out
the
dems and my further evidence of this
is that christine the governor of south
dakota has just flip-flopped on
transgenderism in the right direction
so you'll recall there was a bill in
south dakota some months ago that
prohibited
dudes from playing in the girls sports
leagues
and christie gnome didn't didn't want to
sign it
she was willing to to ban dudes from the
girls sports leagues in k-12 education
but not in college
now why why is this it seems like a
total political winner to me to ban that
it seems perfectly right and natural and
electorally popular
but she said well i don't know we might
lose some sporting events you probably
got a call from the ncaa she probably
got a call from some donors
who do not reflect the views of the
american people or i suspect her
constituents and so she totally squished
on it and that was really unfortunate
well now she's gone in the other
direction
and i'm glad she flipped you know there
are going to be some people who say well
no she's it's not real there's some
trick hidden there in the i don't know
i've read the text of the bill it
doesn't seem like there's a trick in
there maybe it is or they'll say she's
being insincere she's being disingenuous
yeah maybe she is i don't know i have no
idea if she's being sincere on this
issue or not
but i don't really i don't really care
that much
the the people who are saying well she's
not really she doesn't really believe it
she's not doing it for the right right
reasons that's the glass half empty view
of what's going on
the glass half full view is yeah she
flip-flopped to a better position good i
want my i want politicians who hold bad
positions to flip-flop to better
positions and i don't i'm not going to
attack them for it i'm glad i'm going to
say thanks or i'm going to say good job
or i'm going to celebrate
that some some politicians
who are
maybe a little less principled and more
likely to just go whichever the the
winds will blow for their
personal advantage
i'm glad when the winds are clearly
blowing in the direction of what is
right as is obviously the case
on this
sexual identity stuff
speaking of sports
there is a new documentary app
from espn
and this is a documentary on
one of the worst
hate crimes in american history
this is
a documentary about a hate crime almost
as bad
and almost as real
as the attack on jesse smallett in
downtown chicago you remember when
the white supremacist homophobic gay
nigerian man attacked jesse smallet
because chicago is mega country
well this this was not quite as serious
as that but it was it was close this was
the attack
on bubba wallace bubba wallace is
apparently a nascar driver it took place
at the talladega speedway and they found
a noose
hanging in the garage i bet you know we
didn't see it but i bet there were
burning crosses everywhere i bet there's
probably a clan rally happening right
outside the garage right is that what
happened
well if you listen to the trailer for
this documentary that's probably the
conclusion you would draw
the most
incredible
non-competitive moment in sports i'd
ever seen
that moment i could feel the weight of
that moment and and i think we all did
as we were walking
when i
get out of the car
i look back and i was like holy sh it's
a whole garage
the whole garage
that's when i lost it
in the midst of all the turmoil
that was going on in the world
with the black and white the hatred and
everything that was going on
the entire nascar family
rallied behind my son
[Music]
wow just brings a tear to your eye for
how
much the united states has completely
lost its mind
here is the story being told by that
trailer
white supremacy
is pervasive black men can barely walk
out of their homes without being chased
down that's what lebron james said
and this
black
nascar driver found a noose
hanging in his stall from the hate crime
but but
the the
drivers from nasa the whole nascar
family
they decided to overcome their racism
which is so
so pervasive and they stood up and they
said no we don't want to
attack you bubba
we support you and we oppose all those
racists and white supremacists and bubba
was so overwhelmed because because the
default mode in america now is for all
these white supremacists to just lynch
black guys left and right that's what's
going on constantly and amid all the
turmoil
and the hatred of the blacks and the
whites
finally
finally there was a moment of racial
unity
none of that happened it was just a tie
to pull the door down
it wasn't a noose it was a little tie to
pull the door down none of it it had
been there for months and months
it had nothing to do with bubba wallace
it was just a little
tie
yeah it was not surprising
that all these nascar people came out to
support bubba wallace
over this fictional event because there
aren't any white supremacists or
klansmen there it's just it's not real
it's not real none of this is real
there's no the racial the only racial
turmoil in recent years was when blm
burnt the country down last year and it
wasn't white supremacists doing it it
was blm and antifa at the encouragement
of
leftist politicians very prominent ones
including the current president and vice
president of the united states
and to be as fair as i can to blm
i'm not talking about the radicals and
the real leaders and the really vicious
people i'm talking about the regular old
idiots who just go along with it
they did it in no small part because of
the lie being perpetrated by these
people by espn and by the liberal
establishment that there's this
pervasive problem of white supremacy and
that nooses are being left around every
black eyes house
none of which is happening it's just all
fake it's all completely fake
it's not a documentary
it is
a fable it is a legend
being told it is a lie being told as the
truth
by
propagandists
it is a mass psychosis that we are
watching go on
it is it is a kind of religious ecstasy
that you're seeing happen on that track
at nascar
and in the movie and the people being
moved to tears because finally there's a
solution to this problem that doesn't
exist
and and you know what i don't even
really blame them
one i don't blame the people who are
under the spell of the media the media
are very very powerful
but i don't even blame the people who
are engaging in these performances
these performances are religious
liturgies when you go out
and you hold hands and you
sing about the racial unity or frankly
even when you go out and loot and burn
like blm did it is a kind of religious
liturgy and man is a religious being
okay and we need some kind of religion
because we know that we're not quite at
home in this world
we it's kind of weird that we didn't
create ourselves we just came into being
we know that there are things like
beauty and truth and right and wrong and
goodness and morality and joy and we
can't make sense of it because those
aren't physical things but we see the
physical world and so we know that there
is a spiritual and metaphysical world
but there's no satisfaction to those
longings in a world that tells you that
that religion is bogus and christianity
is fake but we still have that desire
and so we fall into new religions weird
kooky racial religions neo-pagan
religions that are divorced from reality
such as
the racial narratives going on
in our country right now it is no
coincidence that right now a new study
that came out from pew research
three in 10 americans have what they
think is no religion this is up 10
points
over the course of 10 years they say
they have no religion
they're calling the secularization the
de-christianization of a marriage it's
de-christianization but these people
don't have no religion they just have a
different religion because nobody has no
religion because everybody's got to
serve somebody
there
is a new religion it's just
way weirder and way less true and way
more destructive than the old religion
we had called christianity who you serve
in man what what religion are you taking
part of and what connection does that
have to the real world i'm michael
knowles it's the michael noel show see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire
on today's episode one of the nation's
largest school districts pushes back its
vaccine mandate elon musk winning person
of the year causes a stir and what
exactly is in buildback better
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire